unser reporter paul ronzheimer diesen
krieg von anfang an miterlebt noch bevor
die ersten bomben fielen war er im
donbass und konnte alles kommen sehen
über zwei monaten in kiew ist er jetzt
wieder dorthin zurückgekehrt direkt an
die frontlinie wo die russen jetzt ihre
angriffe konzentrieren nachdem sie in
kiew und anderswo gescheitert sind hier
ist sein bericht
bereits am ostermontag begann die mega
offensive von wladimir putins armee im
osten der ukraine
seitdem bombardiert russland städte und
ukrainische position in der region denn
jetzt
die straße die richtung frontlinie führt
nennen sie die straße zwischen leben und
tod weil so häufig russen auf fahrzeuge
von artilleriegranaten raketen alles was
sie haben jetzt ist bild reporter paul
ronzheimer zurück in dombach
wir sind im schützengraben bei donets
nur 600 meter vom flughafen von dort
entfernt und hier finden immer wieder
heftige kämpfe statt das sind die
schützengräben nicht schon länger
ausgehoben wurden aber jetzt wird es für
die ukrainische soldaten hier besonders
ernst im don was die russische armee hat
mehrere dörfer eingenommen den
vergangenen tagen und versucht sich hier
weiter einzukesseln 50 bis 60.000
ukrainische soldaten will man einkesseln
und die schlacht ist immer heftiger
geworden in den vergangenen tagen
[Musik]
die russischen streitkräfte haben das
tempo ihrer angriffe deutlich erhöht die
besatzer greifen praktisch von allen
seiten intensiv an und nehmen ziele
unter dauerbeschuss hier entscheidet
sich putins krieg hier sollen die russen
tausende soldaten einkesseln ich habe
keine angst das ist mein land das ist
meine heimat ich sehe meine kameraden an
der direkten frontlinie kämpfen sie
werden nicht zulassen dass der feind uns
ein kessel
putins großoffensive in der ost ukraine
geht unvermindert weiter moskau strebt
vor allem weiter nach voller kontrolle
über die gebiete lohans und don jetzt um
einen landkorridor zu schwarzmeer
halbinsel krim zu etablieren hören immer
wieder angriffe von den separatisten als
separatisten gebiet in dem fall
russische armee die auf ukrainische
position in die richtung schießt bild
besucht die soldaten im schützengraben
die hier tage ja wochen lang ausharren
um ihr land zu verteidigen der krieg hat
sich verändert sagen sie
das ist nicht mehr der krieg von
maschinengewehren und ein kampf mann
gegen mann das ist ein krieg der
artillerie geworden deshalb brauchen wir
schwere waffen hier um uns zu
verteidigen
die militärische spezialoperation in der
ukraine und im donbass so nennt der
kreml diktator den angriffskrieg werde
all ihre vorgegebenen ziele erreichen
sagt putin doch ukrainische truppen
wehren sich und ziehen sich nur zurück
wenn es nichts mehr zu verteidigen gibt
weil alles zerbombt ist
und jetzt gehen wir noch mal in den
osten der ukraine zu paul ronzheimer
paul ich habe vorhin schon gesagt du
warst vor ausbruch des krieges dort
jetzt wieder was hat sich in den über
zwei monaten verändert wenn du jetzt mit
den menschen deutsch sprichst
die menschen haben mehr angst
insbesondere die zivilisten thomas zwar
haben sie sich an die sie reden die auch
jetzt wieder hier ertönen gewöhnen dass
es ein ganz seltsames bild man sieht
gleichzeitig kinder draußen auf dem
spielplatz und die sie reden das hätte
ist vor zweieinhalb monaten je so nicht
gegeben aber auch wenn man sich an das
gewöhnt hat wissen viele was in den
nächsten tagen wochen auf sie zukommen
kann insbesondere diese dörfer diese
städte hier wo ich stehe thomas mann
glaubt dass die einzige lung der russen
passieren kann und egal was die
klinischen soldaten den natürlich tapfer
und mutig dort stehen du hast sie gehört
in unserem beitrag aber sie sagen ja
auch wir brauchen artillerie um uns zu
verteidigen und diese schweren waffen
die dort heute im bundestag beschlossen
wurden die kommen für den krieg im
donbass zu spät
ja du hast es gesagt der kiew und andere
städte konnten die ukraine vorerst
verteidigen haben sie auch im donbass
eine realistische chance den russischen
angriffen stand zu halten
ja sie haben eine realistische chance
zumindest haben sie eine chance dass die
gebiete die die russen einnehmen dass
dieses gebiet nicht immer größer wird
das ist die ganz entscheidende frage vor
allem erst mal richtung neunter mai
betrachtet also der tag die kapitulation
von nazi-deutschland wo wladimir putin
einen sieg verkünden will die frage ist
wieviel gebiet hat er dann und dann ist
die frage wird er weiter kriegen wird er
weiter versuchen hier alles zu
zerbombten im dom bars in lugansk und
dann auch richtung nico sapowicz die
größeren städte dann versuchen zu feuern
oder ist er zu sehr mit mario pohl
beschäftigt dem asa stahlwerk wo er die
menschen aus hungert das sind viele
viele offene fragen auf die niemand eine
antwort hat klar scheint dass er hier im
don bosco ich gerade stehe ganz sicher
in den nächsten tagen wochen weitere
dörfer weitere städte erobern wird auch
deshalb weil das schwere gerät den
ukrainern fehlt hier in dieser stätte so
nennt man das in dombach das platte die
weite dieses landstrichs bedeutet für
die russen am ende vorteile weil du hast
gesagt das schwere gerät das kommt zu
spät jetzt heute interessante meldungen
aus den usa joe biden will die ukraine
mit weiteren 20 milliarden dollar
unterstützen das will er im us-kongress
beantragen und gleichzeitig hat
nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg heute gesagt es sei möglich
dass dieser krieg noch monate oder gar
jahre dauern die nato sei aber zu einer
langfristigen unterstützung bereit und
auch zur umschulung der ukrainischen
soldaten von den alten so wert waffen
auf modernes gerät aus dem westen dann
wäre dieser krieg nicht mehr die selber
die frage ist mit welchen folgen
das ist die große frage thomas
allerdings ist es ja so dass wladimir
putin und seine getreuen eigentlich
schon seit tagen seit wochen mit dem
atomkrieg drohen erst haben sie es
wahrscheinlich in den telefonaten mit
immer neuen makro und oder scholz getan
weshalb auch urlaub so zögerlich war so
gehen die debatten in berlin und jetzt
macht er jetzt ganz offen die frage ist
ist er wirklich bereit dazu denn das
hätte natürlich auch auf russischer
seite massive konsequenzen und dennoch
scheint eins auch ziemlich klar zu sein
wladimir putin will hier ein sieg
einfahren wie auch immer dieser sieg
aussieht und das was aus dem westen dazu
analysen kommt da kann man sagen ist
sich niemand mehr sicher in welche
richtung er geht vor den krieg lagen
viele falsch sie haben gesagt lasst die
mir putin wird nicht bis kiew kommen da
wird vielleicht hier wo ich stehe im
donbass versuchen etwas zu erreichen
aber niemals kiew und jetzt sagen alle
ihm ist definitiv alles zuzutrauen
letzte frage paul kurz zum schluss der
ehemalige berater von bundeskanzler
helmut kohl horst teltschik der ja auch
die wiedervereinigung mitverhandelt hat
hat heute alt kanzlerin angela merkel
als kontaktperson für wladimir putin ins
spiel gebracht nachdem schon ein
altkanzler kläglich gescheitert ist
gerhard schröder hätte sie eine chance
ich glaube da müsste sie schon wirklich
von allen seiten usa deutschland
frankreich aufgefordert und gebettelt
und gebeten werden dass sie da was tut
ich sehe momentan niemanden nicht den
papst niemanden auf dieser welt der
wladimir putin davon abhalten kann von
dem was er hier vorhat das sieht
zumindest so aus wenn es eine
möglichkeit gibt also tatsächlich wenn
es danach aussehen sollte das war die
mit putin verhandeln will dann kann man
sich angela merkel durchaus vorstellen
wobei ob das die ukraine so gut finden
weiß ich nicht laut enisa lenski hat
angela merkel mitverantwortlich gemacht
dafür dass es überhaupt zu dem krieg
kommen ist aufgrund ihrer
russlandpolitik und hat sie jüngst
eingeladen nach butter zu kommen aber
diese einladung der ist sie nicht
gefolgt euro und zwei mal vielen dank
paul